.
>> Laura: NOW, AMP A YEAR PLUS
OF CRUSHING COVID MANDATES,
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOME WILL FINALLY BE FULLY
REOPENING HIS STATE NEXT WEEK,
BUT, AS ALWAYS, THERE'S A CATCH.
>> ONE THING I'M CERTAIN OF IS
THERE'S UNCERTAINTY IN THE
FUTURE.
THE EMERGENCY REMAINS IN EFFECT
AFTER JUNE 15TH.
>> WHAT'S THE REASON FOR THAT?
>> BECAUSE WE'RE STILL IN A
STATE OF EMERGENCY.
THIS DISEASE HAS NOT BEEN
DISTINGUISHED, NOT VANISHED, NOT
TAKING THE SUMMER MONTHS OFF.
>> IS THAT THE WHEEL OF FORTUNE?
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
THERE'S A WORD FOR GOVERNMENT
VIA EX EXTIVE HE CANTIVE.
JOINING US NEWT GINGRICH FORMER
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, NEWT THEY DON'T
WANT TO LET GO OF THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY THEY DECLARE BY
EXECUTIVE ORDER BECAUSE IT GIVES
THEM ALL SORTS OF POWER THEY DID
EXERT WHEN THEY FEEL IT'S
APPROPRIATE WHAT ARE THE DANGERS
HERE?
>> WELL, THIS IS ENORMOUSLY
DANGEROUS AND I SUSPECT IT'S
GOING TO START LEADING TO A
WHOLE SERIES OF LAWSUITS BECAUSE
YOU HAVE GOVERNORS WHO ARE
CLEARLY VIOLATING THE US
CONSTITUTION.
THE CONSTITUTION WAS WRITTEN TO
GUARANTEE OUR RIGHTS AGAINST THE
GOVERNMENT.
AND NOW YOU HAVE GOVERNMENTS OUT
HERE, WHETHER IT'S ON BLOCKING
CHURCHES FROM HAVING SESSIONS OR
WHETHER IT'S DICTATING TO PEOPLE
OR SAYING WHICH BUSINESSES CAN
OPEN UP OR WHICH COOLS CAN OPEN
UP, AND I AGREE WITH YOUR
ANALYSIS.
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT BEING A
LIBERAL DEMOCRAT THAT JUST LOVES
POWER.
IT'S AN ADDICTION.
AND THEY LOVE BEING IN CHARGE.
AND THEY LOVE, FRANKLY,
CORRUPTION.
AND SO THEY USE THEIR POWER TO
REWARD THEIR FRIENDS AND PUNISH
THEIR ENEMIES AND TO TAKE CARE
OF THEIR FAMILY AND TO TAKE CARE
OF THEIR POLITICAL SUPPORTERS.
AND I THINK THIS IS THE LARGEST
BREAKDOWN OF THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION IN THE NATION'S
HISTORY.
NOT COUNTING THE CIVIL WAR.
BUT I THINK IN A NON-CIVIL
WARREN ENVIRONMENT, IT'S
ASTONISHING IN PLACES LIKE NEW
YORK OR MICHIGAN OR ILLINOIS OR
CALIFORNIA HOW MUCH POWER THESE
GOVERNORS HAVE GRABBED.
AND YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
IT MAKES THEM THE EQUIVALENT OF
A THIRD WORLD DICTATOR AND IT
GUARANTIES MASSIVE LEVELS OF
CORRUPTION.
>> Laura: NOW, NEWT, IF YOU HAVE
THE CHANCE TO LIVE IN -- LET'S
SAY YOU LIVE IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA, NOTHING AGAINST
OAKLAND BUT GIVEN WHAT'S
HAPPENED TO CALIFORNIA, THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL STATE I THINK IN THE
COUNTRYING BEING WRECKED DAY BY
DAY BUT IF YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO
LIVE IN OAKLAND OR IN NASHVILLE,
WHY DO YOU STAY IN OAKLAND?
LA VERSUS MIAMI?
THEY'RE DRIVING PEOPLE OUT OF
THESE STATES AND HOLLOWING THEM
OUT.
>> YEAH.
I THINK CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR
LOST $9 BILLION IN TAX REVENUES
AS PEOPLE JUST LEFT.
I THINK SOME OF THE MOST FAMOUS
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA ARE NOW IN
FLORIDA OR TEXAS.
I THINK YOU'RE SEEING PEOPLE
MOVE TO UTAH, TO IDAHO, TO
ARIZONA.
IN FACT, ARIZONAIANS ARE WORD
THAT IF TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS
SHOW UP THEY'RE GOING TO TRY THE
CHANGE IT TO A BLUE STATE.
BUT THE OTHER THING IS DEEPER
AND SICKER AND YOU SEE IT IN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THERE'S AN ENTIRE GENERATION OF
LEFT WING DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE
TOTAL CONTEMPT FOR THE RULE OF
LAW, TOTAL CONTEMPT FOR THE
CONSTITUTION, AND BELIEVE IT IS
THEIR GOD GIVEN RIGHT TO
OVERRIDE THE CONSTITUTION AND TO
TELL YOU HOW TO LIVE YOUR LIFE.
AND IF YOU DON'T LISTEN TO THEM,
USE THE POWER OF GOVERNMENT TO
PUNISH YOU.
IT'S AN EXTRAORDINARY DANGEROUS
ASSAULT.
>> Laura: NEWT, I KNEW YOU WERE
COMING ON AND I COULDN'T WAIT TO
ASK YOU ABOUT THE FREAKOUT OVER
THE AMERICAN FLAG.
LIKE THE LEFT DOESN'T -- THEY
DON'T WANT TO SEE THE FLAG,
THAT'S WHY THEY WERE HAPPY WHEN
THE ATHLETES WERE ALWAYS
KNEELING FOR THE FANS OR THEY
DON'T LIKE STANDING FOR THE AND
THUMB.
SONNY HOFFMAN ON THE VIEW TODAY,
I KNOW YOU WATCH HER EVERY DAY.
LET'S SEE IT.
>> WHEN I DRIVE INTO A
NEIGHBORHOOD, AND IT'S NOT
JULY 4TH AND I'M NOT IN A
PREDOMINATELY MILITARY HOUSEHOLD
NEIGHBORHOOD, AND THERE ARE
FLAGS, AMERICAN FLAGS,
EVERYWHERE, ALONGSIDE TRUMP
FLAGS, ALONGSIDE FLAGS WITH
STARS IN A CIRCLE, I FEEL
THREATENED BECAUSE THE MESSAGE
IS VERY CLEAR, IT'S A MESSAGE OF
WHITE SUPREMACY.
>> NEWT, THEY'RE BASICALLY WHAT
WE'VE THOUGHT ABOUT THEM ALL
ALONG, AT LEAST THEY'RE BEING
OUT AND OPEN ABOUT IT.
>> LOOK, WHAT SHE JUST SAID,ERS
IS FIRST OF ALL ANTI AMERICAN,
ANTI PATRIOTIC AND IN A SENSE
RACIST.
THE PERSON FLYING THAT FLAG
COULD BE AN AFRICAN AMERICAN WHO
SERVED IN THE MARINE CORPS OR
LATINO WHO LOVES AMERICA.
THIS IDEA THAT RED WHITE AND
BLUE IS BAD, I HAVE TO TELL YOU
I DISAGREE DEEPLY, BITTERLY WITH
THE BIDEN'S ADMINISTRATION'S
DECISION THAT AMERICAN EMBASSY
CAN FLY BOTH THE BLACK LIVES
MATTER FLAG AND THE GAY PRIDE
FLAG.
THE AMERICAN EMBASSY SHOULD FLY
THE AMERICAN FLAG, AND ONLY THE
AMERICAN FLAG.
AND THE CONGRESS OUGHT TO PASS,
THERE'S A BILL CALLED THE OLD
GLORY BILL WHICH IS VERY CLEAR.
THE ONLY FLAG WE SHOULD FLY AT
AN AMERICAN EMBASSY I